[موسيقى]
ازيكم عاملين ايه انا اسمي ياسين عندي عشر
سنين النهارده اكلمكم عني بلاش نبدا كده
تعالي نبدا بطريقه تانيه
هل في يوم اتعرضت للتنمر
بيتعرضوا ليه الموضوع ده علشانك ايه هو
التنمر التنمر هو احد اشكال العنف اللي
بيستخدموا طفل او بعض من الاطفال ضد طفل
تاني سواء لفظيا او جسديا ده هو التعريف
الاكاديمي اللي مكتوب في كل الكتب
وممرمط في كل مواقع
خليني اشرح لكم التعريف اللي انا فاهماه
كويس التنمر هو احساس الغضب والعجز والحزن
اللي بتحس بيه لما حد يجي يتريق عليك في
حاجه انت عارف كويس ان ما لكش ذنب فيها
ملكش دم منك شعرك كيرلي او لونك اسمر او
قصير او طويل
لما تحس ان قلبك بيتكسر وانت مش عارف ترد
على الانسان اللي قرر يعمل كده من غير ما
يحس بيه اظن ده افضل تعريف للتنمر لما تحس
انك بقيت تفقد الثقه بعدها ثقه بنفسك يوم
بعد يوم ما بقتش تفرق بين الهزار العادي
والهزار اللي قاصد يجرحك
لما لما
بتحبش تبص في المرايه او بمعنى ادق ما
بتحبش نفسك
ابسط حاجه ممكن يحس بها الشخص المتنمر
عليه او زي ما بيقولوا برضو التاثير
السلبي للتنمر حتى مع الكفته
لا لا مش قصدي الكافيه الحلو اللي بيقدم
كابتشينو انا بتكلم عن انسان للاسف ما
اتعاملش زي ما اي انسان يستحق انه يتعامل
باحترام وتقدير فكانت النتيجه ان احنا
بنضرب به المثل في ابشع صور لاثار التنمر
مين هو كوستا كوستا هو مريح عنده 13 سنه
عايش في صربيا كان بيتعرض من التنمر من
اصحابه ومن المعلمين بتاعه عشان هم هو مش
ذكي
وانطوائي وما بيتكلمش خالص
فادى انه ده انه يتحجز في مصحح نفسيه
دلوقتي
متخيلين التنمر ممكن يوصل لايه علشان كده
احنا لينا دور ودور كبير جدا في القضيه دي
مينفعش نقف في وقتين ما ينفعش نقف ساكتين
وقت التنمر عشان مساعدتنا دلوقتي هتوفر
علينا مشاكل كبيره جدا في المستقبل
علموا اولادكم انهم يطلبوا المساعده لما
يقابلوا متنمرين طلب المساعده مش تعب طب
افرض لو هو ما لقاش
المساعده اللي هو بيطلبها علموا اولادكم
انهم يثقوا بنفسهم ورسالتهم متنمر انت
ضعيف محتاج تفهم سبب ضعفك ايه انت انت مش
بتضحك حد انت مش ولا حاجه انت مش اراجوز
ناس هتقعد تقول لي انت ما بتديش حلول كل
شويه عماله تتكلم المتنمر عليه اه انا
عندي حلول الحلول هي هم ثلاث حلول انه
يبعد عن يعتذر اولا للشخص اللي تنمر عليه
او
يبعد عن الشخص اللي كان بيساعده في التنمر
ثالثا يحاول انه يستغنى عن الموضوع ده
شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]